hey hope you're enjoying your fourth of
july weekend with your friends and
family and hopefully you got the person
that's doing a barbecue hopefully they
know what they're doing because when the
person knows what they're doing it's a
special fourth of july i'm definitely
enjoying fourth of july as well my
friends and family but i just want to
tell you i miss you not just over video
or zoom i miss you in flesh i want to
see you in flesh at the vault conference
in miami first week of september so we
can spend two and a half days together
with the greatest fans curious
entrepreneurs innovators in the world so
we can come up with better ideas
and leave the event finishing 2022
strong so if you haven't yet registered
for the vault conference this is a
special only for fourth of july buy one
ticket get one free bring your spouse
bring your girlfriend bring your
boyfriend your husband your wife your
you know best friend your business
partner bring it with you if you haven't
yet registered click on the link above
or below get registered i'll see you in
miami first week of september